me dirige vers
[Applaudissements]
delà ça va sauter
[Musique]
oh les gars je vais décrocher dans pas
longtemps
romane le romain est dans la place
regarde comme je vais t'éblouir frérot
on est sur ma mission je te rappelle
ressemble c'est qu'on est sur ta mission
je connais personne d'autre qui aurait
mis Anne dans une Alfa
on serait déjà là si romane se travaille
pas dans un lingot sur roulette tu
[Musique]
mon antiquité compense son manque de
chevaux par son agilité
avec kit biturbo IGR stage 3 l'alpha
aura sans aucun doute l'avantage dans
cet environnement
je suis désolé mais
pour les tissés malheureusement
impossible
[Musique]
rien n'est impossible
ce qu'il faut c'est avoir la foi
[Musique]